Should I send my labs? I get to my from my oncologist to labs at cutters clinic.com. Yeah. So please if you get labs anywhere other than from us, please send them to labs at cutters clinic.
Now come what's the best way to do this and actually and should I make an appointment to go over them or just wait until you call them.
So the best way to do it is to download your the PDF of the lab. So you download it as a PDF, you save it as to your computer and then you send us an email and you'll attach that PDF to the email.
If you don't know how to do that, we can help you with that. Some people have given us access to their portals, like their medical portals where they're getting their labs test done or their lab core portals.
That works great too, but then you we don't get notification that you did a lab. So you're going to have to notify us that you did a lab and it's in your portal now.
So please don't notify us until it's in your portal because I'm not going to remember to be looking at your portal on a daily basis to see if your lab is there. But once you get it in your portal and you've given us access to the portal, you can do that. Now, there's some portals out there that don't allow us to save your access and you have to get a pin to your phone each time. Well, that's just not going to work.
Most portals, once you give us your user to pass word, we can access it. We can pull that out. We could I can put that in your file here. Now, should I make an appointment or just wait till you call me. No, the rule has always been you, you know, you have to decide whether you want to go over your labs or not.
Well, how do I know? I don't know if their labs are bad or not. Well, then just make an appointment to do that because, you know, I don't have time to look at everybody's labs and analyze them, you know, and and then decide whether I want to talk to you. Now, there's times that that's happened. So there's times that, you know, I've been in communication with you as an individual and and we're looking for something.
And I told you to get your labs or something and then you said me your labs and I'm looking for it and I tell Marie to call you and make an appointment. There's times that that's happened a lot of times, but lots of times, I don't have time to do that. So if you want to make an appointment, then you call us to make an appointment. So, don't rely on, you know, me looking at your lab, see that something is wrong that I'm having to get back to you. So, you know, make sure that.
Make sure that you, you know, be on the lookout for your labs and tell us if they have them, make sure that we have your luggage, your portal or download your PDF and send it to us and then schedule an appointment. A lot of people send us labs.
They have no desire to have an appointment with me. They're just sending it. They're regular labs on a multi basis. And so we are calling them to make appointments.